chez les filles
tout a commencé lorsque elijah cummings
élus du maryland à la chambre des
représentants a reproché au secrétaire
par intérim de la sécurité intérieure
d'embellir la situation des mineurs
détenus à la frontière avec le mexique
me roesch personne ne laisserait ses
enfants dans une telle situation dit il
ce sont des êtres humains le président
n'a pas toléré ce qu'il a qualifié d'
une critique brutale des agents aux
frontières il l'a publié trois tweets
acerbes à l'endroit de l'élu et de son
district comme ça a été prouvé la
semaine dernière durant une visite de
parlementaires
la frontière est propre efficace et bien
tenu mais juste surpeuplée écrit donald
trump le district de coming est un
désordre dégoûtant fst de rats et
d'autres rongeurs s'ils passaient plus
de temps à baltimore
il pourrait peut-être aider à nettoyer
cet endroit très dangereux et salle en
voulant répliqué donald trump s'en est
pris aux habitants de baltimore une
ville aux deux tiers afro américaines
progressent rapidement une soeur du
second tour le maire c'est une insulte
promenez vous essayez vous voyez tout le
développement que nous avons fait que
nous faisons dans les endroits qui en
ont le plus besoin
lance-t-il la candidate à l'investiture
démocrate elizabeth warren est également
outrée
être attaqué la sorte par un président
qui publient des tweets raciste est plus
qu'une insulte c'est répugnant du teil
la présidente de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi abonde dans
le même sens et selon le candidat à
l'investiture démocrate joe biden donald
trump prouve encore qu'il n'est pas
digne de la présidence donald trump
soulève donc un nouveau tollé deux
semaines après avoir évité quatre élus
démocrates issus de minorités à
retourner dans leur pays
ici andréanne côté c'est laurent radio
canada montréal